this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsay show where america
hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i
am john deloney joined here with my good
friend
you know what he's better looking than
me too mr chris hogan
and today we're going to talk about your
money your life your relationships
what's going on in your heart and your
mind give us a call at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five chris how are we doing
man i'm good buddy and i
am ready to take the calls uh i don't
you know don't try to butter me up john
because you and i will fight on here
we will disagree but you know what
that's part of being real
we don't disagree we do actually we
tangle up a little bit
it's because i'm the kind when and you
are a bit you're a bit rowdy
i just like data and facts and common
sense
you know that's not your strong suit and
that's okay i love the people we got a
place for everybody
and you gave people the number but they
can also find us on social media
at ramsay's show you can find him at
john dalona you can find me at chris
hogan360.
the bottom line is we're here for you
now the way this show works is you pick
up the phone and call
you tell us your issue you tell us the
stuff that's going on in the
relationship
if you're battling some depression some
frustration irritation or anxiety
dr john deloney is going to give you an
answer and if you've got a money
question
you got to call in and we're going to
talk about it i'm going to walk you
through it and try to give you some
guidance
because when you have a game plan john
you can have success i'll i'll give them
an answer but it won't be as right as
yours
well i don't know about all that but
especially listen we
definitely want the opportunity to
referee and what i mean by this is for
you to call in with the situation and
you let
dr john and i weigh in and give you an
answer
and that way we can give you a verdict
and then you can go back and make stuff
happen
man now you're a lawyer and a judge i
get false confidence when i got you on
here
we can do some stuff all right pick up
the phone and call us seriously triple
eight eight two five five two two five
again that's eight eight eight eight two
five five two two five we really would
love to be able to talk to you all right
we're going to the phones uh first and
foremost we've got jesse on the line
jesse how are you
hey how's it going oh focused or not
finished buddy
what's on your mind for john and i to
talk about with you today
all right all right so we got a bit of a
situation here
um your parents left on a week-long
vacation
basically um so this has been going on
probably for the past
five years but um so i am i let my
my first cousin i lent him uh some money
i liked him five thousand dollars
um a while ago and um
he is still have yet to pay me back and
he told me originally that like you know
he just needs it for a job so like
you know i was like okay no problem it's
family like i'll lend him the money and
then
in two weeks he didn't give me the money
and um i guess that job fell through
and i've been asking him especially like
you know right after i called him all
the time like kind of
um almost calling him too much like you
know where's the money where's the money
what's he saying it never and i would i
just said to him directly like hey you
know i know a lot is going on
but um you know i did lend you that
money and like
if you can please pay it back i was even
willing to do like a payment plan things
like that
right and like he gave me a little bit
so i think now the balance is like
around um still like three thousand
dollars but now
there's no relation with him i don't
talk to him whatsoever i used to have
really good relations with him
you know his mom my aunt his kids
everything but now it's just completely
completely done and um and broken and
now i'm just at a point where i really
i don't know if i should just keep going
with it and just keep asking
because that really didn't seem to work
i even asked his mom
um she even paid me a a payment one time
and now i just don't kind of know where
to go from here all right jesse
so you lit him five thousand and he's
paid you back around two thousand
yes exactly yeah and now he now he
doesn't
he's acting like he doesn't know you oh
yeah oh yeah you're a stranger
he actually said that i'm in the room
for um for being childish and not
knowing
about responsibilities because he you
know he does have a lot going on he has
a family
right and he kind of put it on me where
like i'm in the wrong but like
i was willing um you know to to help him
and to do like a payment i understand i
understand
and so i can't wait to hear dr dolony
chime in on us
but i'm i'm gonna go ahead and go first
here if you lent him 5 000
and he paid you back 2 000 let me do
this i'm from kentucky so it takes me a
minute
you got a three thousand dollar lesson
here baby exactly
you've got a three thousand dollar
lesson and you know what
that's why we talk about whenever you
start to get involved with money and
family
without some some and you had
understanding
you said this was alone he called it
alone but now he's acting like
it's not and i think the best thing for
you to do
is to let it go and for you to be able
to move on because i mean
obviously are you working do you have a
job yeah yeah yeah yeah
are you what do you know about the baby
steps
um i'm familiar with them yeah i'm
currently paying off all my debt uh
right now
don't don't play with me jesse my
girlfriend and i what do you mean you're
familiar with them what kind of debt do
you got
um i have some student loan debt i have
17
grand in student loan okay i have um a
car
payment as well as also 17. okay and how
much are you making right now
i'm making uh 40 grand a year okay all
right so
i i if i'm you i mean it sounds like
you've kind of gotten there you're
frustrated and irritated about it
which you have every right to be but i'm
gonna count this as a three thousand
dollar lesson move on with your life
and let this be one of those learning
lessons unfortunately
uh because it's not worth the
relationship you know uh and it sounds
like it to me
it's more of your cousin's issue than
yours yeah when
when you when you loan money to family
don't don't
give it to them for all of your
badgering
um you can put a price tag on the cost
of that of that relationship and it was
two thousand dollars
you you beat them up you got two
thousand bucks back
does he owe it to you yeah are you gonna
get it no and now you're going after his
mom too
what you got to ask yourself the other
day is what's it worth right what's it
worth you got it you got a
a taste of his character you got a taste
of ore
and that may not be a fair statement you
got a taste of some messy situations you
found himself in
either way it is what it is i'm with
chris man let it ride
let have some peace in your heart dude
and is it it's a 3 000
expense there you got a 2 000 price tag
on that friendship
man don't go after his mom just stop
yeah i really would and and it's it's
it's hard man i mean especially because
you know he
i know jesse used the language alone all
alone well in the buddy cousin called it
alone
yeah right that's why he paid back some
of it and
this is one of those things where it can
change the family dynamic
right but i'm going to say both of them
are at fault here
oh yes and you know what i'm not even
going to say the guy asking for money
because
i've been in situations myself man i get
pretty desperate
yeah like uh and i i may ask a question
i normally wouldn't ask right
in those moments someone who loves me is
going to have to put up that boundary
and protect me
help me for myself right yeah and say
man i'm not i love you too much i'm
gonna give you some money
or i'm not i'm i'm gonna say no to you
well you said it the right way
it's one of those where if you're in a
position to do it give it give it away
and and and that way you just mentally
you don't have any kind of hurdles or
issues in the relationship
every time you see him it's not that
weird hey bro that's right i'm calling
you i'm getting after you i'm gonna have
to stop where's my money
you don't want to do that that's rude
all right y'all we're coming back stay
tuned this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help you get there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com
ramsey to find out more
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i am
your host chris hogan and joining me
this hour is john delony and we are
excited to be here to take your calls
uh we're ready people we are properly
caffeinated
wide awake uh john drinks tea um
i drink coffee but it's okay and that's
just so dismissive
it's just the difference between the two
of us and it's fine
but listen we want you to call listen be
quiet john i've got to tell the people
the number to call
the number to call is triple eight eight
two five five two two five again that's
eight eight eight eight two five five
two two five love to hear from you
i harassed this man but he is doing
listen
drinkers are people too i drink coffee
and i'm sitting here defending tea
drinkers
they're all right it's fine john uh
listen he's got the dr john deloney show
where he's he's got new episodes on
monday wednesday and friday
you can catch him on youtube and any
place that you listen to podcasts
you can get real straight talk on
relationships you can get information on
mental health challenges
uh the tools that you need to cut
through the depression to get clarity
and understand the steps to take
you can do it and you've actually got a
quick readout john
uh his book it's called redefining
anxiety
and a lot of people in 2020 found out
they got a little wound up got a taste
of anxiety on a level
probably people didn't understand you
know it we walk through live think and
we control a lot
and some folks say that 2020 remind us
we lost control
now we didn't it just reminded us a
little control of
over anything that we have yeah right
very very little
i mean you think about it it changed the
way we work
yep the pandemic it changed the way that
we
interact with family with each other
each other
church yeah i mean it was a lot of stuff
yeah and i think you know
you've told me before if left unchecked
and not really dug into
it could have lasting rippling effects
man i
my colleagues who are mental health
professionals across the country
you talk about white knuckling it yeah
there's
there's people that are terrified of the
of the the downstream ripple effects
people don't make good decisions when
they're
leaving a season of this sort of this
magnitude of
of a mental and psychological and
and physical challenge right dave always
says we don't make decisions when we're
stressed
man we are coming out of a season of
some of the heightened most heightened
stress any of us have ever endured
like hundreds of thousands of people
passed away and man
we gotta have really band together over
the next couple of years to
to recognize hook man we're all in this
thing together yeah be with one another
because one ridiculous uh decision on
top of another on top of another ripple
so these communities man it can be it
can make a mess right
so we got to get clarity on it and we
got to understand it we got to get real
with ourselves and
and get the right plan and so you know
i've talked about controlling the
controllables that's it
um and and that is a factor with your
money but also in life
so give us a call we're here to help you
gain control we're here to help you
get a clear vision on the next step the
direction you're going
uh and we'd love to talk with you that
number again to call is triple eight
eight two five
five two two five all right going to the
line i've got alex is on the line alex
how are you
hi chris how are you doing oh buddy i'm
focused and not finished how are you
today
um i'm doing good so uh i got a quick
question for you um
i uh we just started a business about a
year and a half ago
and the business is doing great uh we're
good we're
i mean it's just two months in and we're
projecting it
maybe tripling what we did last year um
things are well but i've got
i've got a kind of dilemma because all
these people keep coming to me like hey
man
you guys need to apply for this ppp
money there's like money everybody
else is getting all this money you know
i know a realtor friend they got twenty
seven thousand dollars
this person's getting twenty thousand
dollars like all the stuff
and i've got two philosophies on it like
i've got no problem
finding every single tax deduction to
keep the money away from the thieves
right
but again on the other side of it is
is this a handout because
i'm not looking for a handout i'm i'm
looking to keep the money that i earn
right i'm not looking for the government
to to give me money that i don't deserve
right and so all these people tell me
like well you know
everybody else is doing it everybody
else why don't you do see
yeah and i'm sitting here thinking like
um
you only have principles when it matters
like you show your true character when
it matters and
is this a handout or is this like
getting tax money
back right you know okay i just need to
let me hear let me tell me this what
line of work are you in
um plumbing you're in plumbing and how
many team members do you have
three and you said business you opened a
year and a half ago business
is not just doing well it's doing great
you're saying you're about to triple
your
your profits your in your uh revenue
from from from a year and a half ago is
that correct
right okay and business has been good
for you
so i'm gonna tell you this this ppp loan
this and i'm glad you called it alone
because that's exactly what it is
people started calling it a grant people
started calling x y and z
here's the reality the role of that
money for this
loan which you and i both know alex
alone is something you pay back
uh with this it could be used for rent
it could be used for paying your team
members there were specific things it
could be used for
here's the issue people are just now
following through and trying to submit
to find out
how much of this is actually going to be
forgiven and then how much they're going
to owe
so i'm going to i'm going to tell you
this a lot of the people that are
telling you and that are
are hyped up about hey got this free
money first of all number one it wasn't
free it was a loan
and the amount of paperwork they're
having to jump through right now
i'm going to tell you something they've
got a rude awakening happening
because people are submitting these and
from what i've heard from at least four
of my banker friends
on average about 45 of them are being
declined
which means that people are now going to
start to get the payment
uh plan that they're going to need for
this money so
if i'm you i'm avoiding this like the
plague
even when businesses were calling in
during the pandemic
and talking about it i was trying to let
advise them do everything but this
like this is not something that is ever
going to go away so if you owe the money
you owe it to the government uh they'll
take as long as they have to to come get
it
or or come after you so it's not
something i'd advise and i
i love his his heart on principle
right yeah so you find yourself out on
an island right when you start looking
around
and this is this is not just about
people that's about anything right i've
got this principle that
i want to work real hard and if i need
help i'm going to ask for it i don't
need any help but
everyone else is just taking this is a
free fall i'm an idiot here right am i
missing out
yeah what am i what am i doing here and
his
his heart his i've got a principle with
that says
i don't borrow money i work really hard
and i keep i want to keep what's mine
fair right
and that's it yeah
so should i go ahead and violate my
principles because everyone else is
no yeah no no right i really wouldn't
and and the mindset around it again
of you're having to submit paperwork to
find out how much of this is going to be
forgiven
or what your bill is going to be and
let's be honest men
we don't have this money to be loaning
what do you mean we as we the people do
not have this money to be loaning
it doesn't exist and so we're going to
pay it back
soon no it's the government it's all
going to pay back later we print it we
just print more
christopher no i know man listen to me
it's a problem all going to have to pay
this is
a problem it's a it is a problem
whenever you start adding
billions and trillions with a t yes to
the bottom line and we're doing it with
the stroke of a pin
it's going to be a problem we're going
we're going to
have to that bill is coming it's coming
and you know who's going to pay for it
my kids all of us my grandkids yeah
all of us people who had no role in this
no participation in this are gonna be on
the hook for it
because i couldn't say no yeah because i
couldn't have hard conversations i
couldn't live within my means
and are there people across this country
struggling holy smokes yes
right without a doubt i'm all about
helping my neighbor yes
but when good folks like this say am i
crazy for
living within my means right no or that
you had businesses that were making
millions upon millions applying for this
ppp loan it's like come on people wake
up
get a grip all right listen stay tuned
when we come back we're going to take
more calls and dig into more of your
questions
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
chris hogan and hosting along with me
this hour is john doloni
we are excited to take your calls and
talk about the things that are on your
mind
uh let's do the blinds.com question john
uh
you know as we look at this you and i
know blondes.com 100 satisfaction
guaranteed
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsay
to get the best deal rules and
restrictions apply
so today's question comes from paula in
california hey
she asks i have a universal life policy
i've been paying into for 25
years i no longer need a policy as i no
longer have anyone who depends on me
i called to see if i could cash it in
and it's not worth much
but i feel like i should keep the policy
since i've paid so much into it
what is your advice okay well i mean
when looking at this paula first and
foremost
if you're saying you don't need it
anymore that means you're either a
built up enough wealth that you're
self-insured uh so you don't have a
reason for it you've got money to be
able to take care of your expenses or
you don't have anyone that's depending
on you or your income so i mean with
this this
universal life policy this is a whole
life policy
so essentially what happens with this is
you end up paying on it for your whole
life uh but but when you die
the only thing the family would get is
the death benefit portion of it
so any of the cash that you've built up
uh
would go back to the insurance company
what and so oh yes
oh yeah i didn't know that yes so here's
what i would do
i would definitely get get with an
insurance eop
find out what the surrender charges are
in this and what cash is in it
and go ahead and deal with that pull
that out you're going to pay taxes
obviously on the gain of that
but go ahead and pull that out then you
can start to use that towards your baby
steps
so if you're a baby step six and you've
already got your house paid for
then what you could do is you could do
some giving with that or some extra
investing
but if you don't have a need for it
there's no reason to let that sit there
now let's say you're out there and
you've got whole life or universal life
and you say uh oh hogan dave said it's
not good i got to get rid of it slow
your roll
first and foremost what you have to do
is get a term policy
full and in effect okay don't cancel
anything
until you've got another policy falling
in effect because
you might be deemed uninsurable you
might have a health situation
and if you can't get anything else then
you have to keep that you
want to hold on to that but you want to
get term life insurance
10 to 12 times your annual income so if
you're making 550
000 a year or you know then you're
looking to get 500 to 600 000 in term
coverage
and xander can help you with that so one
of the coolest things in my life is i
get to just sit on this show next to you
and dave and that and learn stuff and
last week i learned some stuff sitting
with dave talking about whole life
and i feel like i just learned something
else so
i this is not uh theater this is me
almost speechless which is a rare thing
if you ask my family members
because i i didn't know this is how this
worked so let's say i go get a whole
life insurance
and they policy and they say great so
tell me this is how this works chris
i say i want a hundred thousand dollar
policy and they say great
effective today whole life policy
hundred thousand dollars if you die and
there's a cash benefit of 25 000
but you got to give us 200 bucks a month
just for the rest of your life right
so i say great so i live 10 years
15 years and i'm just giving them 200
bucks 200 bucks 200 bucks 200 bucks
when i die
my family didn't get that money they get
that they get the death benefit
so if it was a hundred thousand dollar
policy with a 50 000
death benefit yeah and you pay on that
all of your life yeah
they're getting the 50. now that's if
you haven't taken out any loans
so if you took loans out against it of
10 000 or 20 000
and you only had a 50 000 death benefit
but a 20 000
loan now when you die the family's only
getting 30.
so really i just paid for somebody else
to have an awesome life
you paid a heck of a fee at a heck of a
premium for life for a very small amount
of
thousand dollars to get back to let me
have half of my money yes
yes that was nice of me well and so it's
the mindset around it of
you know what's why we tell people you
want to buy a term and invest the rest
so term is going to be term life
insurance is the cheapest way to get it
and i know i've talked to people and
they say you know from an estate
planning standpoint an investing
standpoint
they'll look at that whole life and
things of that nature but i'm talking
about for the average
everyday person of looking at it of just
having wanted to have coverage if
something happens to me
money's coming to my family and that's
where term life insurance is going to be
your best deal
so it's one of the it's it's it's like
folks who overpay their taxes because
they feel like they get a bonus at the
end of the year
right yes it's not a bonus no it's not a
bonus it's your money
but the government was holding on to it
because making it just on it
and then they give it back to you how
nice is it and so we got to get smarter
and so if you're out there from
teachable moment here
if you've out there you've got life
insurance through
through your job i want to tell you
that's not the way to go
because if you lose or leave that job
you've also lose and lost
left behind that insurance so get term
life insurance outside of your job
uh that way you've got the coverage if
you decide to go start a business
you decide to go do x y and z do it now
john another thing with life insurance
if you're planning to have another kid
or adopting another kid you really want
to look at this and rethink your life
insurance
do you need to increase it do you need
to you know
add more to it and please don't forget
if you've got someone that's working
in the home they need to make sure that
they have coverage as well
because if you're the one working and
something happens to you
the family's getting money but if
they're the one at home taking care of
kids and something happens to them
you also need money because you're gonna
have to hire someone
to come take that to work to help the
kids or you're gonna have to move closer
to family
so this life insurance stuff is serious
business uh you can learn more go to
ramseysolutions.com
uh or daveramsey.com learn more but
really look at where you are
this year and get the right amount of
coverage again 10 to 12 times your
annual
income is kind of the the benchmark
there of how much you want to get in
place
and you again make sure if you've got
someone working inside the home they're
covered as well
and i've said this before on this show
i'll say it again
man i've been behind closed doors at 2
30 in the morning looking at a spouse
whose husband or wife has just passed
away in the other room
and they were the breadwinner and they
look you with it's a very particular
look
when they look at you and they say the
scariest words i can hear which is
what do i do now right like
i gotta go to work on monday because we
can't pay a rent next you know i don't
know what to do
yeah right because we had nothing yeah
right and nothing got me on the life
insurance track
faster than sitting with person one
person two person
i'm not going to leave my wife in that
situation right i'm just not like
leaving my kids in that situation
they need to be able to stop and grieve
and go through their life that's right
go through their life
and not have to worry about hey mom's
got to go to work tomorrow yeah right so
i mean
if you're out there and you've got
someone depending on your income whether
you're taking care of a niece a nephew a
grandkid
you really got to look at this and think
about it now john i've told people
if you're single and you have no one
depending on your income
and you've got an emergency fund which
could take care of your final expenses
then life insurance is not something you
need but if you've got people depending
on your income
it is an absolute must and you know a
lot of people are fearful of it because
they don't know
and i'm just going to tell you straight
up because that's what i do you're
you're they're going to come in for life
insurance they're going to get your
height your weight they're going to get
fluids
okay you're gonna get fluids uh and then
from there it'll take six to eight weeks
in order for them to
to put the policy full in effect and so
get it done
we have no reason to delay no reason to
to hold back we've got to make sure we
get this stuff in place
all right gotta get it gotta handle it
and so you know that's just one of those
real things we gotta talk about
sometimes
just because people can think can get
scared and if you fear what you don't
know
most people as you were know if it's
fear they freeze
well and it's same as making a will
getting life insurance doesn't increase
the likelihood that you're going to die
no right and people will think that i
know they don't like to think about i
want to talk about it so i'm not going
to do a will i'm not going to do this
right
it doesn't increase the likelihood no it
does increase the likelihood that
when you die which you know spoiler
alert happens to everybody
that the people you love will be taken
care of that's right that the state
isn't going to be figuring out
where your kids go and who gets your
house and they're not going
your family's not gonna have to go rush
off to get to work hey quick quiz from
someone's
not necessarily unnecessary knowledge i
know you know what it's called if you
die without having a will
it's called dying intestate
now you can win jeopardy with that one
baby listen stay tuned
we come back to ramsey show we're
getting back to the phones cause you got
questions and we got answers
stay tuned
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
chris hogan and hosting along with me
this hour is john delony
and i can't tell you how excited we are
to talk to you
we're about to get to the phones but i
just want to let you know the phone
number
the number to call is triple eight eight
two five five two two five
again that's eight eight eight eight two
five five two two five
uh phone lines are open kelly is
standing by and ready to take your call
and we'd love to talk to you all right
we're going to get to the phone line we
got a caller here we got
james uh is calling in from milwaukee
james how are you
hey i'm good guys how are you doing oh
we are focused and not finished buddy
what's on your mind today
all right so similar to a previous
caller got a bit of a
situation here with a rental property of
ours
my wife and i are uh amateur landlords
at best but it's been fairly lucrative
for us over the past
eight or nine years okay looking to get
out of it but we do have a
tenant that's been in our our best
property that we're going to be putting
up for sale soon
that hasn't paid rent in about a year
went through the
went through the eviction process uh
and actually you know got the notice uh
to serve him and
ended up not going through with it
because it was february
he had no place to go and so we let him
stay with the agreement that he would
you know
really start to um pay back what he had
owed
yeah um he was back at work things were
turning around
um but that money hasn't come to us um
so he owes us about thirty thousand
dollars at this point
um and just wondering what the best way
to
to proceed with this is we want him out
um
but i also want that money so do i is it
a civil lawsuit once we get him out of
the house
what does that look like yeah this is
tough man i'm sorry
uh because it sounds like you have been
beyond
understanding like you guys have really
tried to work with this guy haven't you
correct yes and he's made no effort to
pay you whatsoever
no he hasn't paid in about a year and
and the rent is
you know it's a really nice house about
28 2900 a month that he pays us so
right he paid for the first you know
year or so and then he
he ran into some hard times um and i
know he's gotten stimulus money and i
know he's back at work
but none of that money has really come
to us so will he meet with you have
y'all have you all sat down and had a
just a conversation like over a table
yeah the only time
the only time he he met with me is
when i when i showed up it was a little
surprise visit yeah
um we actually don't live in the area
anymore um so it's about a two-hour
drive to get there got true i mean i got
i got other stuff going on at this point
i just want to be done with it but
obviously we need them out but you but
you are you guys are going to sell this
property
yeah and we should clear you know we
should clear a couple hundred thousand
that's good that's good but but from the
principal standpoint i don't
right now i want the money that that way
no i understand
um and you are gonna have to consult
with an attorney yeah
you really are uh because and and here's
the crazy thing
james not only you're going to have to
consult with an attorney but you're
going to have to do some math
on a what's it going to cost me to to
try to pursue this
and then all right and and keep
reminding yourself as you well know you
still have 30
000 that you haven't received and so now
you're going to spend more money
to to potentially not get or get some
money
and so you what that's what i mean in
that consultation with the attorney
is to understand the likelihood and the
and the
probability of you getting any money
i love the fact that at least you're
going to sell it you're going to net out
you know what that property's worth but
i you know you
you've got to do kind of a cost benefit
analysis
on you know in that consult and you'll
pay 500 to 1 000
to sit with the attorney to walk through
it but you know
in that meeting you want to know how do
you have to properly notify him that
it's being sold
uh also when he has to vacate and that
vacating process
for him to get out uh for you to be able
to show it
and sell it and all of those things uh
john his guy's been over backwards yeah
the the the chances of getting that
money are very very very very very very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very very very slim right yeah
so unless this person is just piling up
cash
and has zero character which i think's a
low probability
right i think more realistically he fell
on real hard times has nowhere to go
and took advantage of somebody who
wasn't gonna kick him out was gonna work
and work
right after month two month three
suddenly the rules don't i mean
i'm okay i'm i'm gonna keep plugging
along right so you look up and it's a
year later
i think you're right chris and and james
i i think you're gonna have to sit down
and do the hard math
the soul math what is it gonna cost you
in sweat equity what's gonna cost you an
attorney to go after somebody
even if you get a judgment against him
they're gonna say great you owe me
thirty thousand dollars he's gonna smile
at you and say
it might as well be 30 million dude i
don't have it right and they're gonna
evict him
and then it's gonna be on his credit
report you can high five then you're
gonna have a lawyer bill
right right that's right um at some
point you think of it this way
if there was thirty thousand dollars in
a box two hours away
who wouldn't get in the car and drive
over there and pick that up right so at
some point you gotta get in the car
drive down there
have a conversation um go through the
eviction process have that
it's been a year right that's it's super
generous
go through that process i don't think
you're gonna see the money i don't man
that's a lot of sweat actually a lot of
money
i really don't get anything i really
don't and you know the other side of it
is
is james going the bigger picture math
of what that property's worth you are
selling it
um i think this is uh this call my
friend
uh is going to be a lesson for a lot of
people uh when you are looking to rent
not only do you want to get quality
people with references but security
deposits and
you know and it's still that chance you
know there's still that percentage
chance of people going crazy
or not doing what they're supposed to do
and that's one of those life lessons
uh to look at this and so get get have a
consult with an attorney
uh get some guidance you and your wife
sit down and really be prayerful and
careful
on on how you're gonna go about it
because what what i don't wanna see you
do
is to spend a hundred thousand one after
thirty right
and you know you'll at some point in
your head you'll feel validated
but ultimately mathematically and i like
what you said soul math
mathematically speaking you're going to
look and you go i
i i lost twice i lost three times
uh with this and there's a better way to
go about it and if you're listening to
this
and you've fallen on hard times which is
100 of us
right 99.9 of us falling on hard times
and we've found ourselves in a situation
where we need somebody to step in and
help us out
whether that's with wise counsel whether
somebody has reached out and given us
you know we i've had an envelope show up
in my mailbox during seasons of my life
when
people are struggling somebody
says hey i understand like james did and
they come to you and say
oh man your life fell apart you're in
our best house
we're gonna let you stay we're gonna ask
you to step up when
when you can man if you
don't do anything that next month and
that next month and you don't
communicate someone is helping you out
here's the meta lesson here don't ever
help anybody out
and i'm the guy always running around
saying help out your neighbors help out
your community
and we get a year here no communication
no
nothing and i don't want the message
being don't ever help no i enjoy hard
times
they do but man if somebody helps out if
somebody has helped you out you're
listening to the show right now and
you're not doing right by them
and you may not be able to come up with
thirty thousand dollars call them
communicate
call yeah i would tell people you know i
used to be a debt collector
many many many years ago i would love to
see you come to my house yeah i would
not have
but but it was pd pre-dave yeah uh but i
i you know on this side of it and being
a financial coach i would tell people
if you can't pay you can at least pay
attention communicate and that paying
attention is communicating
uh call them don't be a hostage in your
own home with the bill collectors
calling you
pick up the phone call them communicate
about your situation but john i would
tell them this
if you're somebody communicating to a
collector don't try to don't expect
their permission
don't expect them to be understanding
that's not the goal of the communication
the goal of the communication is
information exchange
let them know listen i know i owe you x
y and z
this is what i can afford to send in
this is what i plan to send in by the
30th
right and then do that stick to that but
eat call them
like you're saying call them communicate
on the front end over communicate as
much as possible
when you're in somebody's debt whether
it's a gift like james gave this tenant
or
it's money like a previous caller it
lays on you like that
we call that shame blanket it gets
heavier and heavier and the thing that
feeds shame right it's
an old bernie brown thing secrets and
silence it feeds that stuff man
so if you suddenly somebody does you a
solid and suddenly the next month shows
up you can't pay
yeah you gotta swallow them yeah you
gotta pick up the phone and call them
let them know what's going on
talk about your situation taking care of
our neighbors oh man what a fun hour
listen want to thank everybody for
tuning in thank all the callers for
calling in
uh we love hanging out with you connect
with us stay with us
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life and your money
i'm chris hogan and hosting along with
me this hour
is dr john dolone and i can't tell you
how excited we are
to be here with you and ready to take
your calls
so here's what we need you to do pick up
the phone and dial this number
888-825-5225
again that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five
if you've got some questions out there
whether it's dealing with relationships
anxiety uh job change
money questions whatever it is we're
gonna do our best to guide you
all right john are you awake and ready
to go i
am man what have you what have you been
working on in your show i mean i know
you
you're always doing something these days
i mean we
are um talking about relationships and
mental health and school
and physical health and work everything
that's going on people's lives
right how do you handle it when you find
things out about your
spouse or your boyfriend girlfriend you
need to know about yeah how do you
handle things when your kids show up
with
special needs or special challenges or
medical issues all of it all in one big
bundle man just helping folks make the
next right step my goodness that's a lot
of stuff
but it's stuff that people are going
through and it's called life that's
right and the most important thing to
know is you don't need to go through
life alone
uh you need to get the right people on
your side the right information so you
can make the right decisions
so give us a call we're excited to talk
to you uh we're we're going to the
phones
uh because that's what we do we've got
jason who's in traverse city michigan
jason how are you
i'm doing well good good to speak with
you chris john
yeah how can we help you today bud well
i am
a future everyday millionaire that is
trying to get
past how to get to that point with a
financial decision that i'm looking at
i've been debt-free since 2013 i
i have no debt i've got money packed
away
and i'm looking at purchasing a property
uh mini storage
units because i got a late start on my
retirement and i think this would be
a a fast track to getting a retirement
income
post work that will supply me with
a steady income in my years of
retirement basically okay
so what for what you're looking at
what's the dollar amount
all right so here's what i got the
property currently has one mini storage
unit on it plus one large
coal barn with storage the property is
generating only about a thousand dollars
a month
so it needs to be expanded so i'm
looking at a
four hundred thousand dollar mortgage
essentially which will include
the purchase and erection of two new
multi-unit uh buildings which
in turn will allow me to have a much
larger shovel to dig out of this
debt the income that comes from this
property is not needed
uh i run my own business and i can
easily live off
my my current income as well as
if necessary pay for this property on
top of that
okay so you what how much are you making
a year right now
uh let's let's just round it into a
medium of
80k okay and how much money do you have
sitting ready to be used as an
investment uh minus my emergency fund
which is a pretty healthy emergency fund
uh let's say 100k liquid okay
and so in looking at this in the
multi-unit how many units are you
talking total
uh two buildings two additional
buildings with approximately
32 to 36 units per building okay
32 to 36 and the average rental price
would be how much per unit
uh granted you'll have different sizes
five by five five by eight eight by ten
ten by twelve
but on average what's the storage fee
uh i've done an overall calculation and
i know that each one of these buildings
on a conservative occupancy
with conservative rental rates should
generate between 25
and 3 000 a month and that's that's not
max
max capacity obviously okay what about
these buildings is over and above the
thousand dollars a month you're
generating
now uh
i'm sorry are these new buildings you're
gonna build bigger fancier
what makes them different the current
the current mini unit that's on there is
only a 16 unit
uh building
is it old is it full at capacity oh yes
yes yeah yeah
yeah absolutely yeah that one's full of
capacity and there are
the the large pole building has just
open space for
random space storage okay yeah
cars boats hey jason you said you had a
super healthy emergency fund
i of course that jumped out at me how
much over and above
a six-month emergency fund do you have
uh let's let's call it another 40 000.
okay so 100 so essentially push come to
serve you got 140k
that you could use toward this if i
needed to but
tell me if my logic tell me if my logic
is correct here or if i'm
going in the wrong direction part of the
reason i want to keep as much of my
liquid cash available is that way i can
use that for
better negotiations for concrete work or
building erection
uh rental equipment to do excavation
things of that nature i got you
along with just having just making sure
yeah here's the deal i can hear it in
your head you're a serial entrepreneur
um and you are itching to take on debt
and and and that's where philosophically
we're going to differ
like you know when i look at this and
say hey first thing shirts in any
business i'm going to tell you to work
on a business plan i want to know what
competition is in the area
how many other storage units are there
in in your area or the area you're
thinking about living
are they at capacity or the is it an
oversaturation
uh where there's too much also you also
have to be aware just like with a rental
property
yes you do have these things that you're
putting up and it's new and on the
starting you're gonna do it but what's
the rate of people falling off the wagon
and not paying
then you're having to now go in and do
auctions and clear-outs of this thing
so i i don't think it's as passive as
you're thinking it is
is this something that in a year you got
140 000 let's just say straight up that
you could use in capital uh could you
get a little bit more intentional you're
self-employed making 80.
i think you're pulling my leg there a
little bit uh you might be making more
than this
but but looking at this is this
something i would strive to do with cash
absolutely i would or a very short-term
loan
where maybe you're you're you're
financing 50 50
of it uh and i'm saying if then uh to me
i just
you i i i feel like you're going to not
only do this but then you're going to go
on and do something else
and the next thing you know you're going
to look up you're going to have a
million dollars in debt and wonder how
you got there
so i would adopt a a cash debt free kind
of mentality
with any business that you're going into
uh to start small
and maybe you start small maybe you
start with what 140
000 get me can i get that to capacity
and get that humming
and then save up money to be able to add
the next one instead of
building the grand poobah i'm just build
a little pub that's right and
anytime you're trying to do something
to quote-unquote play catch-up yeah i
feel like i screwed up in the past i
haven't invested enough and so now i'm
staring down the barrel of retirement so
i found a shortcut you start doing
napkin math that makes that shortcut
work for you so you can forgive
yourself for the challenges you did in
the past yeah don't make another mistake
on top of
other mistakes there you go when you try
to hit a grand slam it increases the
odds of striking out there you go so
just stay focused on hitting base hits
people
base hits with cash it'll get you there
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out
at chministries.org backslash
[Music]
budget
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show all
right everybody
we know it's that time of year it is
it's tax season and i know you're out
there and you're going ah hogan really
really listen i know no one wants to be
bothered with taxes
but you finally have an easy way a money
smart way to be able to file
online now there's other software out
there that'll do it but i'm going to
tell you this it's not what it's cracked
up to be
they say it's free but no turbo tax is
not free for the vast majority of people
that use it
they sign you up and then they increase
the price
basically from free to 40 from 40 to 60
to 120 or even more
now we're not going to play around like
that uh the cost to file a federal tax
return with
ramsey smart taxes crystal clear it's 17
or 37 depending on the level of support
you need
so if you're single filer you can do it
for 17 bucks
if it's a little bit more complex and
you need some upgrade to get live help
37 will do that but it's not just about
the cost
the technology that we have and the
support that we're going to have
for you it's it's second to none and
we're never gonna leverage your
financial situation and sell your name
off to
other lists i.e credit cards or other
companies out there because that's what
a lot of these tax filing companies do
they'll sell your information off to
other companies so
let's do it right the first time sign up
for ramsey smart tax
take a look at it you're going to get it
done uh you're not going to pay a thing
until your taxes are right and you're
ready to click file
so you got an opportunity to kick on the
tires and check it out all you have to
do is text the word tax to 33789
again text the word tax to 33789
got to get that out of the way so you
can unclog your mind and feel better
about your situation
so here's here's an an insider view
we do commercials here right we got we
gotta make a living
right i use this this weekend
i had a gap between like a family thing
we were doing i had to take my sister to
the airport she came to visit us so i
had a small amount of time
i sat down used this program did my
taxes now i'm a simple guy so without
anything complicated going on
i got all the way through it so like you
said i got to test drive it
all the way through didn't have to pay
until the very end of it
it was simple it was fast it told me
exactly what my
refund is going to be hit a button that
says file it
filed it done dude it was awesome
wow no uh for real yeah
listen i pretty much came to work today
on a covered wagon
my horse is sitting out there like i'm
not a sophisticated guy
you crack me up i can do taxes on my own
by myself on my kitchen table
that's a big deal it's just simple for
us but listen i want to encourage you
out there i know some of you are like oh
i've been meaning to do it
i was going to gather up my stuff but i
just found something else to do
listen don't you paint that don't paint
that room again okay
don't paint or i know people would
rather move than deal with taxes
or paint i know don't go out there and
rearrange your garage for the third time
get this done you're saving my mail and
now listen
you might have a complicated situation
you might be a self-employed person or
you may be a business owner
we've got tax elps that can help you
with that as well
uh you go to daveramsey.com click on tax
elp
you can find a tax professional in your
area the main thing is is let's not
prolong it 2020 was goofy enough
let's get these taxes done get this
behind you and know what you're dealing
with
all right that's the commercial people
happen make it happen
all right we're gonna get on the phone
we got uh oh cj's on the line
uh cj how can dr john and i help you
hi guys how are you i'm so ex i'm so
excited to talk to you
i'm excited to talk to you what's going
on
well i have a question so um i've been
dating someone for about five months
and uh this you know we've been married
before and uh we're both 60.
so um i'm not exactly sure when the best
time to talk about finances would be
and if you guys have any suggestions on
how to broach that subject
is yes that's a loaded one that's good
so
what is your financial history
well mine personally i've been through
the program so i don't have any debt
um i own my home and i have a good
retirement
uh you know i'm still working but but
it's looking good for
for retirement for me so um
usually i hear somebody ask this
question on on
one end of a barbell they have
they have just their finances are a
wreck and they're ashamed to talk about
it
or they've really been diligent they've
just
chipped away and chipped away and
chipped away and they find themselves
where you are they got a good job they
got a paid for house they've got no debt
and they are worried that this is going
to be the deal breaker or the you're
going to find
this is going to be the one thing that
me and
my this person who i've been dating
don't agree on it's just going to burst
here's what i would tell you this is
never about money it's always a values
conversation
and so i would approach approach this
the same way you approach any other
value
sit down and have a conversation right
five months you've been dating a while
you get to know this guy you both have
been through this this you'll both have
been married before y'all been in this
rodeo before
there's no surprise at this point i'd
sit down and if this
five months actually i think it's a long
time right i would've had it beforehand
i'd i'd do it with a smile on my face
we're talking about money
cj do you think you all differ on this
money stuff i do
um i i did ask him if he's you know if
he did dave ramsey's program and he
hasn't yet
uh but our church offers it sometimes so
he's he plans on
going through the program when the
church does offer it again right
had he ever heard of dave before
of course yes okay okay um so what's
your apprehension about the conversation
well i i don't really know how to bring
it up and um
have you kissed this man what have you
kissed him wait a minute here deloney
if you've kissed him cj you can talk
about money
okay ah i see i knew it
okay first of all john has just
overstepped the lie
he is overstepped cj hey hello chris
here's why i say that
when i was i'll never forget doing my
counseling practicum
people would tell me the most intimate
things about their lives
real intimate stuff chris i get it i get
it
and then i would say tell me about your
finance situation
locked down nothing yeah we have such a
sense of discomfort
and shame around money and if we have
been doing well with it we tend to feel
a little bit better than everybody
around us right
it's just this thing and i think it
comes back to our culture if we we ask
this one question
hey chris what are you worth and we as a
culture define that as a number
right not a number of people who love us
and our kids
right so all to say is this you're going
to just approach it the same way you
would any old conversation i do with a
smile or face and say we've been dating
for almost half a year now
and we've talked about politics because
i know you have we've talked about
pandemic stuff because i know you have
you've got
relationships you're kids pastor you've
talked about all of it
it's time to go into it and get into it
and and cj i would even tell you
of the money things you want to find out
do they budget
what's their feeling about debt right do
they have money saved for retirement
i would just make this conversation the
one and what i mean by this
is this is the make or break any of the
other questions you've been thinking
because i know cj you got other
questions too don't you
well you know um not really we've
covered
some of the other big topics
listen listen you're so sweet you are a
southerner
that has moved to arizona because i hear
the twang in your voice you're a
sweetheart
listen here make the list of questions
have the conversation
uh but i you know in that and i agree
with john it's
it's like anything else if you want to
know you got to talk about it uh
but that being willing to uh to connect
and go to
through financial peace university or
plug into ramsey plus together
i'm on fi i'm gonna put the where the
rubber meets the road uh and this is one
of those where your talk and budget
especially if this is long term
if you guys are just hanging out to hang
out and there's not a long term plan
then then you do your money things
separate but if you're thinking about
getting married and thinking about being
a couple
it's something you got to talk about and
if i would listen
to the hesitation yeah if you're
uncomfortable five months in talking to
somebody who's been through as much life
as you two have
and you are nervous about this
conversation you don't know how to bring
it up
that tells me there's some other alarms
going off about this relationship and it
could be that maybe cj you money was
used as a weapon against you and your
previous relationship
either way again put the cards on the
table be able to talk to each other
gain understanding then gain agreement
on the right direction and then start
working in that direction
but remember you're separate until
you're married that's right so you work
your plan and stay focused this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
chris hogan and hosting along with me
this hour is dr john deloney
uh we're pumped up and ready to take
your phone calls so all you have to do
is pick up the line
call us 888-825-5225
again that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five
we'd love to be able to hear from you
and talk to you about what's on your
mind
so if you've got a question whether
you're dealing with relationships
whether you're dealing with stress and
anxiety and needing some guidance
dr deloney will help you and if you've
got a money question you want to talk
about building wealth i want to talk
about dealing with retirement
i can help you we're here for you you
can find us on social media
at ramsay's show or hunt me down at
chrishogan360 or hunt john down
at john delony we have finally got him
some social media
so you can find him on there and he's
he's learning you guys dragged me into
the 21st century and it is not going
well here
it's a lot isn't it i'm telling you man
it is a lot without
the twitter and and and and facebook
instagrams and all of it all the things
but i tell you we love connecting with
you all
uh and help john and i defeat christy
and rachel
uh we are trying to outgrow them so
definitely follow us
tell your friends to follow us uh we
must win this battle
it's just it's a necessity or we'll
never hear the end of it all right we're
going to the phones we're
excited to take your call we got kristin
is on the line kristen what's your
question for john and i
hi so um my husband and i are
funding our 401ks at 15 good um
but if we stop so we've reached uh baby
step four
or five because we're funding for our
kids college funds as well
um but my question is is
what was i'm 25 so if we stopped
or not stopped but dropped our
percentage of allocation to the 401ks to
5
and paid off the home in two and a half
three years would you recommend that
overpaying
into our 401ks or what would your
thoughts be on that okay kristen how did
you tell me you are
25. where'd you guys learn about this
money stuff
um actually dave ramsey i had a class in
high school personal finance
um and it was one of the best things
that i ever seen when i was 25 i didn't
know what day it was
well that's that's a that's a that's
another show that is another show that's
another show
uh christian i'm impressed seriously uh
because
at 25 i wasn't thinking like that as
well
so uh the fact that you're at that point
it's awesome you heard the information
uh and not only did you listen to it but
you guys have started to apply it
okay so you're asking do you cut down
your
your investing down to the the minimum
the match and take every other extra
diamond to throw it toward the house is
that correct
yes yes no okay
and here's why i would love you guys
have the ability i want you flexing that
muscle of doing the 15
matter of fact i want you doing 15
regardless of the match the company's
doing
okay so you guys are doing your 15
i still want you throwing extra money
toward attacking the house
all right now why do i say that because
remember compound growth is the thing
that's the game changer
compound growth is what's going to help
put you all on the next level
so you all can do both for example
what's the household income for both of
you
it's 130 and we put and so i can
make i'm gonna have it like three years
i was hoping to speed it up by pausing
that a little bit but right
uh about um i allocate about 4 four
thousand
dollars a month toward the house payment
yeah yeah yeah see and and here's the
other thing you're not factoring
your income growth over the next three
years
okay yeah so you all again i would just
continue to do the 15 the compound
growth is gonna set you guys apart
because you all are laying the
foundation right now financially
uh to become everyday millionaires uh
literally by your late 30s
so i would not i would not cut that out
i would continue to do your 15
but then throw all extra money uh toward
attacking the house but here's gonna be
the secret weapon also kristin
are you you're the saver in the
relationship aren't you
yes your husband bless his heart
does he is he still eating ramen noodles
or what do you let him eat
actually no i i like her i'm just
playing he eats what i say you can hear
the focus
and so i want you guys to make sure
you're still having some fun
you know you're one of those people i
got to give this lesson to because
you're
you you see and you attack right you're
you're so goal oriented but inside of
that just know
you guys can still go out to eat and pay
cash you guys can still do some stuff
uh and that's important and kristin the
reason i'm bringing that up is
i'm trying to get you guys ready because
once you build wealth
i need you to be able to enjoy it so
it's just that mindset of giving
yourself a chance
relax breathe a little bit yes you can
still attack the debt you want to get
that out of your life but you're not
going to forego saving for retirement
so chris help me with this
i bought a house i haven't owed anybody
money in a long time
and i recently took out a mortgage by a
house i did it all the
the right ways if you will right
it's killing me i hate
showing somebody money yes i hate it i
hate it
yeah and we've sat there with a
spreadsheet chris
and i can do it this fast right if i
just hang on and then i can cash flow
college and then i can catch up on my
talk me out of it man
so you have thought about yourself for
going maybe
retirement for the second time yes suck
it up
and then do a couple of speaking gigs
here right right
and i can quit feeding my kids on
saturdays we can do it okay don't stop
feeding your kids they're nice
bring them to me i'll feed them but here
here's the thing
with people that um i tell people all
the time when your income can fluctuate
or you can earn extra money
there's nothing wrong throwing that
extra toward the house okay but i
wouldn't forego saving for retirement
or or forgo saving for college the
reason why
is is the compound growth is the thing
that gets exponential
yeah okay so don't get in the habit of
that four or five and six that
investing 15 percent saving for college
and throw an extra at the house
i don't have a problem with any extra
dime that comes in
it going there but not at the sake of
having uh the retirement taken care of
because here's the deal
these kids that people tell me they love
so much if you don't save for retirement
you're gonna burden them
that's their problem i'm just kidding
they're gonna have to take care of you i
know
yeah but no i love the intensity it's
just one of those money
you know yeah i know but look at it if
if again the home
how are you getting it out of your life
as fast as possible and and for people
that
can earn chunks of money or bring in
some extra income
i tell them all the time fire every dime
at that but please don't forget to
budget for some fun
like don't don't don't forget you got to
have some blow money in your pocket
of course you can you're getting out of
debt are beans rice rice beans
right the only restaurant you see is you
drive by it that's right i see it on tv
right but when you get out of that mold
that four five and six it's a marathon
not a sprint but i get it and that
detesting it
that's what will cause you to pay it off
even faster than you think you will
that's right like that thing's gone
because if you
have something you'll start thinking
you'll go boy you know what if i do this
or this or this to bring in some extra
money
you already know where you're going to
send that money to yeah you know you're
not going to be upgrading vehicle or
anything like that you're
seeing my car you have the mindset you
have the mindset of this debt's got to
go
that's right and the challenge for me is
i want it gone so bad
that man i could sit down at a
spreadsheet and make the math work in my
favor
or more importantly it's it's the
psychology of it it is right
it is but like you said having been
debt-free now as you make the decision
to buy a home
because you were doing the on-campus
living search
for you it's that looking at it and i
like that i like that you don't like it
but looking at it you're going okay i've
got a systematic plan
i am going to feed the kids all seven
days of the week
right you are going to do that but you
have a plan that's right that's good
though i like that you're intentional
with it man it tells you that you go you
don't feel right
nope you know and i tell people a
mortgage debt that's the only debt that
we're okay with you getting and i'm not
even okay
but that's that's a good thing that's a
good thing because here's the thing you
won't be
house hopping in three years you won't
be thinking of going to buy x y and z
you're thinking i want to own this
outright that's right
then that's the way to go if i look back
over the history of time any house me
and my family are
fortunate to live in with an air
conditioner and a roof we're on house
money man
i mean we are playing on house money hey
dude it's called having perspective
and awareness it's a beautiful thing all
right stay tuned when we come back we're
taking more of your calls
there's no telling what we might do so
stay tuned so you can check it out
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show we are
excited to be back with you i'm chris
hogan and co-host along with me this
hour is dr john dolone
we are excited to take your phone call
so we're gonna jump right to it
uh we have got uh christopher's on the
line in huntsville
alabama christopher how can we help you
hey guys this is a question about a 529
my wife and i have a five months old
congratulations
well thanks thanks uh cozy kid
it's uh it's been fun because that's
gonna be the name right you're like oh
you're a covent baby right
is this your first oh yes it is
how are you guys doing uh good she is
finally sleeping through the night so
we're celebrating yeah that feels like a
minor miracle right there
when you get that full night's sleep you
can go oh to be human again it's the
only celebration that results in
going to bed earlier good for you guys
great job buddy so
what uh you guys are saving for college
so what baby step
are you on so uh we just bought our
house
uh back in december and uh
so we we've done the flip to the 15
uh investing in our in our 401k
good and everything so now we're on the
529
and we started a five to nine and
we were thinking about front loading it
um
let's say that instead of investing
consistently
uh you know the last caller you talked
about some of the compound
interest and everything with it that
basically
uh let's say by age one for our child
that we put 20
we put 20 000 in there is that enough
growth if we stop at 20 000 uh for her
to be ready
when she graduates from high school
ready for college or would you recommend
to
put let's say after the 20 000
500 a month biggest thing is the
compound interest
is what we're thinking okay so do you
all have the 20 grand liquid right now
to do that
no but we bring in some good income
okay let me say that well the child is
five months old how much do you owe on
the house
uh we owe about two hundred and ten
thousand
okay what's your household income about
260. 260 000. what do you guys do
i'm an engineer and my wife is a nurse
practitioner okay
so here's the thing your kid is five
months old you guys have a strong income
or as we call it a big shovel uh i'm
gonna be
more apt to you guys doing three grand
uh
a year uh toward the the 529 and throw
every extra dime toward the house until
it's paid off
then you could easily jack that up to
five grand a year in the 529.
okay yeah and so i you know i want you
to get the number one
that threat out of your life right now
and that's the debt on the home
you guys got a massive income
christopher can i tell you this how many
more kids do you want
uh well i we're in our young 30s and we
think this is the last one
okay see i i tried to ask you a trick
question there
and i'll be dog if you didn't answer it
the right way he's smarter i
asked you how many do you want and i
wanted you to throw out a number and i
was going to say how many does your wife
want
but you said we think we're done the
reason i said that was as you're
thinking about it as you guys are
setting this up with the 529
there will be enough growth there if you
guys are doing that
you know three grand a year throwing at
that thing you're going to be
more than fine uh but but getting the
house paid off and then shifting it to
now where you're not having that
mortgage payment
but instead of what you were paying on
the mortgage you now start to invest
you guys are going gonna be great how
old are you all christopher
uh well we're uh my wife's 34 and i'm
about to turn 34.
okay yeah you guys are you're you're
doing great i mean you're on the ball
buddy
uh i like the mindset that you all have
in the intentionality
you're gonna have a great opportunity to
be able to to be 100
debt free and make sure you've got your
education paid for for your kid
that's huge yeah that's incredible and i
leave it to an engineer to crank out a
spreadsheet the moment that kid's born
and say all right how much against this
that's
awesome i love that heart it is that
they crack me up man because they're
thinking
that's right you know and again you know
you can't get somewhere without a game
plan and some forethought
so it really takes that uh but it ends
up being it goes back to that same
question i was asking you earlier which
is
for him for me it's that that thing
weighing on my soul
that makes me want to throw the plan
away and just go after this thing
is my is my mortgage for him it's i
gotta make sure this kid's college is
taken care of
that's right let's start playing it
right now if i take this chunk and i
dump it
yeah right and and it is it's a matter
of breathing and understanding but then
it's the process
and you know what i found people want to
understand the why
the what and the how yeah right and so
going back to that and i love when
people know their why
because that's the thing that will
motivate you the what and the how you
can get to that but that why is that
root thing
that keeps you engaged to it of people
that are you know trying to get into
shape trying to get stronger or
whatever it is you're trying learning a
second language whatever it is that y
is just gonna gonna fuel you some people
have a why of
growing more hair have you ever tried
that okay
okay first of all i can grow listen
let's go over to the youtube guys check
this out
hey hey don't even think about it don't
even don't even think about it
there's a photo of my good friend chris
listen
this is taken two weeks ago two weeks
ago
he i saw chris in the mirror he was
clenching his fist really hard
if you're listening this on the radio
chris man he had
a illustrious head of hair he shaves it
off on purpose
those of you who are that are listening
to the show delony has dug into the
archives and found a photo
for me of just just a few months ago
we have it here this is actually from
way back in the day
uh so this proves i can grow here a
handsome guy
it is it is and i just prefer being bald
it's just
i like to let my scalp breathe and and
so
that's what i'm doing that's honestly
what i'm doing uh while delony has
harassed me i'm gonna take a moment and
tell you about the chris hogan show yeah
no
seriously uh you i when i look at my
show numbers they get they high-five me
and they're like hey man you're doing
really great and then i think yeah
that's what's up and then i look at
yours i'm like nope
not doing good christopher what are you
doing on the chris hogan show listen we
have a lot of fun we're take callers
obviously
uh but we do a segment called did you
know and this is where we get an
opportunity to give people some
some information that maybe they didn't
know for example of the episode that is
airing uh
actually aired this week we gave people
five
things that millionaires invest in and
so we call it did you know and there's a
graphic that'll pop up
and you can see it and i went through
the five things according to our
research study
because we talked to over ten thousand
millionaires of what they're investing
in
and just real quick i'm going to do it
like david letterman style let me guess
it's bitcoin and gamestop not at all
john
if i if i had the gong show i'd gong you
no john
they invest number five personal growth
study of millionaires showed that people
are active and intentional they impact
their future
number four relationships being mentored
asking for help getting guidance when
you need it and that's you you preach
that all the time
have humility stop it number three home
ownership
millionaires are likely to own a home
than the general population
and on average millionaires pay off
their homes in about 10.2 years
see john europe have yours paid off in
like 4.4 i have no
doubt number two iras investing in
things will allow you
taxable investments where you can start
to put money away to start to let it
grow
and the number one thing the number one
tool millionaires use
employer-sponsored retirement plans
401ks
403 beats ira's roth iras
the opportunity to put money away it was
the number one tool
that helped them grow wealth so all this
to say
hold on so real estate wasn't on there
that surprises real estate
it wasn't in the top five other things
other than your yeah just real estate
personal home
home ownership so mindset so you've got
an opportunity real estate was in the
top ten okay
just the top five so these are the kinds
of things we talk about on my show uh we
take callers we take questions
uh love opportunity to connect with you
on youtube as well
as you can see i'm a little animated i
make some faces every once in a while
uh and i got a flag that i throw if
somebody if there's an article out there
that gets me riled up enough
i throw a flag on them so check it out
flag at me go to chris
360.com you can find out more about the
show uh or find it any place that you
can listen to podcasts
what what would you if you had to
distill it down right now what is the
most
what's causing people the most
apprehension about their retirement
about what's next oh i think it's just
the unknown of what's going on with this
pandemic
yeah everybody's got opinions and the
stock market is we're seeing is riding
like a roller coaster
but the unknowns and so that's why i
tell people go back control the
controllables
all right listen everyone thank you so
much for tuning in this hour uh we want
you to stay connected with us we love
your calls and we love your support this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money i'm chris hogan and
hosting along with me
is fellow ramsay personality dr john
deloni
and i have to tell you we are excited
excited to talk with you to take your
calls
and to find out what's on your mind so
don't hesitate any longer pick up the
phone
give us a call at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five again that's
888-825-5225
or hunt us down on social media i'm at
chris hogan 360.
john is at john delony and you can find
us both of us we have shows
uh that you can go to youtube and
subscribe to
john's talking about relationships
emotions
anxiety and feelings i'm talking about
money building wealth retirement and
high definition dreams
so both of us are here to help you and
we'd love to connect with you today to
talk about
what's on your mind so john are you
ready let's do it
all right you're taking notes over there
you must have had some thoughts
what what i have two or three i've had a
couple okay very good very good i'm just
checking i didn't i didn't know
tell me this uh best call you've had on
your show recently
oh man uh the best call i've had
they vacillate between folks who are
calling in to celebrate something is
good in their life right um
the the most difficult call i've had
recently we took one yesterday they'll
come out in a few weeks
was a young mom
of a four-year-old who's heading in for
a surgery
that just has some bad news written all
over it
and how do you tell the four-year-old um
how do you prep yourself how do you prep
your marriage yes just it's as real as
real can be
that's exactly right you know what do we
do what do we do next yeah okay
wow listen tune in to the show uh any
place that you can find podcasts you can
find the dr
john deloney show uh dr john deloney
d-e-l-o-n-y
get over to youtube uh i have had an
opportunity uh to listen
to several of the episodes um and the
callers
uh the hearts behind it uh the the
emotions that are there
uh it's real and at the same time you
have an opportunity to hear
people get real hope and an opportunity
to get off the call and begin to
understand you can almost
hear where they're stuck yeah hear where
they're hurt
and hear where they're alone that's
right and this alone stuff
is no joke i tell you what i at i was
joking with uh dave the other day i i
asked a few folks when the show first
kicked off they would ask such
hard intimate
deep questions my first response is why
in the world are you calling me
right like i just some dude on the radio
what are you right
and one you know we trust you
and two i got nobody else and that that
was
a hole in my heart right now i thought i
was in this gig
you know like because people wanna my
wisdom and what man there's a lot of
smart people
it's about i got nobody else i trust you
being available i'm gonna call you
you're a safe person that's not gonna
holler at me and scream at me that's
right beat me up and we're gonna get
through this together
yeah well that's the thing that's the
same with the retirement questions i
know
i know but you you you've walked through
some stuff and you've seen some stuff
um and you know the main thing i know
you do is you're you are considering the
individual
uh you're being real with them being
upfront and honest but it's still a
person
yeah uh and you're not somebody you're
not looking just uh you know to
to do hollywood and to to do something
you know uh the outlandish and crazy
you actually hear the heart behind the
person uh which i think is phenomenal
and i think it's it's admirable brother
so appreciate the good work
uh keep guiding people and uh again
check out the show you can get on there
on youtube
have a chance to take a look um you know
the show is doing fantastic
he's yet to have me on there so i take
it as a personal affront
um but it's fine we're gonna do this
a bald only episode coming up you gotta
do some kind of ism it's coming
uh and that's fine that's fine it's not
gonna be about all right listen to me
uh i've had enough of john already uh
but i i wanna talk to you
john does too triple eight eight two
five five two two five seriously people
we are here for you
let's get on the call and we got robert
on the line robert how are you
doing all right how are you doing there
chris hey we are doing fantastic my
friend how can we help you today
uh well um i got an opportunity coming
up
um i'm going to be uh doing an interview
tomorrow
with a new company i'm a truck driver by
trade
okay um and the
the uh the main question i have is
if i do get offered the job tomorrow
should i pause
baby step two at least for a couple of
weeks so i can have a little bit of a
buffer because i won't be getting paid
for two weeks
once i get uh once i get
um entrenched in the job
okay so you're in baby step two uh
you think it'll take a couple of weeks
for you to get your income ramped up
wouldn't you be do some back pay from
the other job
i'll be doing one week's pay so that'll
cover
you know part of my bills but it'll be
right at the beginning of the month
i got you so once all my money comes out
because i save up during the month and
the off everything at the first of the
month
so once that money is gone it's gone and
i'll have maybe
with my income i'll have about 500
um okay tell me this what kind of debts
do you have
robert i have a student loan
of 25 i have five on
one vehicle and nine in another vehicle
you got the
uh 5 000 vehicle was repossessed
about a year ago and i'm working with
them to try to pay it off but
it's been a little harder than you
yeah i would expect yeah and so uh how
confident are you in this job
this new one i'm pretty confident um i
got a friend
uh i got a friend who actually works
there okay so i already have an
in like with ken coleman if i get it in
so i got that part
good that's good i i'm just trying to
you know if i do get off of the job
position it'll be it'll be a substantial
pay increase
well that was my next question so
realistically what you have there's
obviously your fixed expenses
you know your rent and things of that
nature the student loan and then the
nine thousand dollar car
you're not even doing anything on the
five thousand dollar repo car yet right
no no sir yeah yeah so i mean i don't
think i i mean do you really have to
pause
uh anything um but if you did yeah
there's nothing wrong with that while
you're adjusting and getting into your
next job
i mean that's just normal uh and in that
phase of life now
what you want to do is to make sure
you're keeping everything tight and
clear
right and taking care of the things that
are absolutely necessary uh but no i
love the fact you're gonna be making
more money that's a good thing
yeah it's just just keep yourself on
track man it's easy when you pause it to
go ahead and
i'm gonna go ahead and get i gotta have
a couch well you know what i was sitting
here gotta get a new tv
you know what i know about me i am a
celebratory spender i will
silly okay listen to me like i talk
about this on the show you need to know
be thinking about what kind of spender
you are uh but you i i wanted people to
know what kind of spender are you
are you a board spender are you a lonely
spender yeah
are you a a celebratory spender yep you
know what i mean are you a sad spender
you gotta okay you have yep to all of
them
do you really i like spending all right
listen but i'm always down for a
celebration
especially when you're celebrating me
yes and you know what i realized
it's not how much i spend it's just that
i spend so i control it in the budget
gotcha instead of two hundred dollars
maybe i celebrate with twenty dollars
see but you need to know what kind of
spender you are so you can check out
that episode of the chris hogan show
it was it was hilarious and it was
eye-opening for you board spenders
you stay off that amazon don't you even
go over there and look
find something else to browse like the
john doloni show with the chris hogan
show
we'll be right back this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show we are
excited to be with you i'm chris hogan
and hosting along with me is dr john
deloney
we are excited to take your call but i
want to tell you this
because here at ramsey solutions we're
focused on transforming lives
and we know that we can help
bring hope like wildfire across the
country and so
imagine a world where it's weird to have
a student loan instead of everyone
assuming that that's the only way to get
an education
or imagine a world where the majority of
people pay cash for their cars
or credit cards are like the cigarette
of the financial industry
imagine being a part of causing that
level of disruption
with the work that you do every day here
at ramsey solutions we have about a
thousand people at our company
that are working together to create
digital products and services to help
people
transform their lives with the goal of
disrupting the toxic money culture
that exists in america today so if you
want to join
us on that crusade we're currently on
the hunt for many software engineers
with expertise in ruby on rails java
c-sharp and other front-end technologies
or if you're a ux designer seo or
content marketing specialist
we'd love to be able to talk to you so
you can find out about
all the available jobs by texting work
that matters all together work that
matters
to 33789 again text the word
work the words work that matters
to 33789 and you can find out about
all of our existing openings it's got a
great opportunity
uh you can get plugged in and know
exactly what it is you're dealing with
uh and the type of people you're dealing
with because it's it's uh this place is
unique
that's really a statement of the century
it really is so
we'd love to have you join the team and
uh help us grow
all right we're getting back to the
phones because that's what we do
here the number to call if you've got a
question i want you to pick it up
uh kelly is awake and standing by a
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
again that's eight eight eight eight two
five five two two five we'd love to be
able to hear from you
i don't know i said wait of course she's
awake uh i'm have to deal with that at
the break but anyway let's get on the
call
i got rachel on the phone rachel how are
you i'm good how are you chris
i'm focused and not finished what kind
of question do you have for doctor john
and i
um so i recently started the baby steps
about a month ago i'm on baby step two
um i actually am brand newly engaged as
of this weekend
congratulations thank you so much
um so i of course i'm trying to plan
ahead now and i'm just wondering if you
guys have any advice or tips on
what the best way um to you know plan
for a wedding or
whatever you know i can do to
contribute towards that while also doing
the baby stuff okay i thought you were
going to call in and ask us if you
should sell the ring
and apply that to your debt and the
answer is yes
sell it sell that ring girl pay your
student loans off
just kidding don't do that rachel don't
do that seriously though
tell us what kind of debt do you have
right now
um so it's a little bit of everything so
i have a car payment that's
7 700. i have student loans
that are about 21 000 and i have a
combination of credit cards and personal
loans that are 38 000.
how much of that is credit card um
let me see here this ballpark is
uh like 20. okay what was the personal
loan for
um it was from my parents and one was a
debt consolidation personal loan
okay so you kind of got the you kind of
got the buffet of debt
you were normal yeah what do you mean
what kind of debt are you married into
i'm sorry what kind of debt are you
marrying into good question
um just student loans he has student
loans but nothing else
how much um about a hundred thousand
okay he just glossed over that one no
just student loans it's cool
it's it's a lot 7.9 million
in texas okay yeah so all right how do
you pay for a wedding
while you're in baby step two it is
going to be absolutely crucial that you
guys get on the same page
uh to this and gain agreement rachel i
i want to tell you something i have seen
people spend
20 30 and 40 000 on weddings
um and it's absurd it really is and
i think when you try to end up doing the
party of the century for the family
instead of it being about you and your
fiance beginning your life together
that's where it can begin to take on a
life of its own
and so i think you know like in your
head can i tell you something the tip
your fiance needs to know
like does he have any idea how long you
plan to be engaged before you want to
get married
um we were i think we were kind of
talking about it just ballpark
like maybe two years okay because dudes
don't know this
we we have no we we don't know there's
not a guidebook out there
so tell him and talk with him about that
uh but i'm serious
i think it's really important for you
guys to do this as cheaply as possible
uh being very intelligent and here's the
other one
having boundaries and guardrails for
family members
what i mean by that is you need to find
out are your parents planning to
contribute did they have a wedding fund
those kinds of things are important to
know so you can know how to begin to
navigate this because it can get really
sticky
two two year engagement tell me about
that
um well we've been together for six
years already um
we live together we've lived together
for a year um
so really though like our our marriage
is just kind of like a
solidification of what we already like
are doing kind of
so it's defining our finances it's a way
bigger deal than that and if you look at
the data
folks who get married afterwards after
they live together
just because they're cementing things
man there's
not a great uh this is just the data
right and i haven't looked at if you use
any circle back to it but
the stats would tell me i want you to
take
the the idea of getting married it feels
like we're just
hey man we're just gonna go through the
motions and do a thing that we're
already doing
it's a bigger deal than that it changes
everybody from the inside out and it's a
big deal
that said why wait two years you're
already living together you're already
right there why don't you go down to the
jp this weekend and get married for 78
there in new jersey yeah i mean i would
like to
um he it's more of our families that are
the
boundary in that i've suggested several
times even before we got engaged
that we just go solidify it at the
courthouse or whatever yeah
is he home is he is your fiance there
right now
no i was gonna tell them both to raise
your right hands i was gonna do it right
here uh
listen here your parents your family has
nothing to do with this
yeah this is your life what do you mean
are they the issue
is it your parents or his um
it's mainly his parents my parents want
a destination wedding
listen here the here's the deal all
right now adam got riled up the one here
on my head is wiggling
rachel listen your parents want a
destination wedding
tell ask them what's their budget and
when do y'all need to show up that's
right
okay that's exactly right yeah tell them
feel free to pay
to play to plan it yeah you'll be there
let you all know the date
and you'll gladly go do your reviles
right again but no i'm serious i agree
with john let's go on get this thing
rolling
listen get down there do the justice of
the peace then you guys can say you know
what fam
it has been a tough year 2020 has been
crazy
this is how much we're planning to
contribute mom and dad
you guys have talked about a destination
do you have a wedding fun or were you
just
talking and and it's a nice way to do it
but
okay how old are you rachel i am 24.
you're full-grown
you are full-grown no seriously you are
full-grown
and i want you and your fiancee
seriously to sit down and be real with
each other
and say hey what do we want to do now i
know you try to be considerate and
and trust me for your parents your
wedding day is a big day
uh but this is this is a day of you know
you can call it a confirmation day or
wedding day
you can call it whatever you want that's
semantics i like the idea of you guys
going on and getting it done
and working together that's right so i
want to encourage you three things
number one to go back to your original
question
make a pact with your fiance you will
not borrow money for this event yes
period number two it is okay to pause
baby step two and pile up cash to make
sure you pay for this wedding but do it
responsibly not to save up money to get
a forty or fifty thousand dollars
you guys owe a couple hundred thousand
dollars okay
and then the third thing is get with a
premarital counselor get some skills you
think this is just going to be a
just a a further extension of what it's
been it's gonna be different
honor it that way go into it will eyes
wide open learn some new skills you're
gonna have a great
marriage ahead of you guys do it the
right way and do it quick
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
chris hogan and hosting along with me
this hour is dr john delony
but listen i'm going to tell you
straight up 2020 was a crazy year
people dealt with a lot of changes a lot
of issues but here's the deal
if you're tired of feeling stuck with
your money
if you don't feel like you can ever get
out of debt or feel like you can ever
save enough for the future
now's the time this is the time you have
an opportunity to make a change in your
future
right now you can make progress with
money
and you can do it faster than you think
but it only happens one way
and that's with a plan and so ramsay
plus
is the plan it's going to give you
access to the premium version of our
every dollar budgeting app
you're going to be able to plan every
dollar you spend before the month begins
you're going to be able to connect your
budget uh to your bank account so you're
on
every transaction and know what's going
on and you have the ability
to get custom budget reports so you can
figure out where your money is going
and target your money towards your gold
so when you budget and you get
intentional with your money
you will make progress and you can do it
fast
all you have to do to get started today
to start your free trial of ramsay plus
is go to daveramsey.com
again that's daveramsey.com and you can
start with ramsey plus today
it's a great opportunity to get serious
about a plan
and i'm telling you once you do it
you're gonna be
able to run down the road of progress
and really see hey i'm living
differently and i feel differently and
that can be a game changer
all right we're getting back to the
phone we've got uh john on the line
john what's your question for dr john
deloney
hi um you know i'm in a
a pretty difficult difficult marriage
it's always been a really really
difficult marriage
and at this point um we're living
separately
and you know divorce has been has been
sort of
discussed plenty she's trying
desperately to avoid it i'm trying
desperately to avoid it
and um you know it's it's one
of the aspects of you know the many many
complicated things that we're
in the middle of is finances where
you know there's a significant amount of
of
you know of just not being honest about
finances
um happening on her side and i sort of
you know patiently kind of walk through
these steps and and try to
try to you know figure out what to do to
move forward and
i guess my question is ultimately you
know to what
to what extent and you know how much of
the decision
process that you know i'm facing
is appropriate to be focused on
on finances i really really don't feel
comfortable
um divorcing my wife because of
finances when we can certainly make it
um but then there's a bunch of other
problems
that that are even bigger um
i don't know if that if that makes sense
to the question yeah so i
i guess first of all i wanted to tell
you a minute i in here you're
hurting and i'm sorry for you um i'm
sorry for your wife too
being if you're both as you to use your
words desperately
trying to stay connected and you feel
that thing just full and pulling apart
further and further and you're trying to
hang on trying to hang on
um that's that it feels powerless and it
feels scary and
and man i hate that for you so
i almost i don't think i've ever
experienced an interaction with a couple
that was having you know here they we
call it
you know financial infidelity right
where somebody's lying about money
they're being deceitful around money
i've never experienced that with a
couple that it didn't have
ripple effects into other things as you
mentioned so
tell me what's there's something bigger
going on here what's what's the bigger
thing in the water here
you know let me ask you this way you
would you wouldn't be divorcing your
wife because of the money thing there's
something else there's other things here
going on
i i agree i agree and it's you know and
i think that you know
truthfully there's been a lot of um a
lot of our experience the early years of
marriage where we were
you know we were swinging in the same
direction and and really working hard we
both have
um you know some healthy habits with
finances
um but it is a situation where the more
finances
you know the better our finances became
the more
disunified we were
um but yeah your bigger question
i don't know how to answer that without
jumping into a complaining session about
my wife on the radio which i don't want
to do
sure but but it's been you know it's
it's
you know there's times when the marriage
just feels wonderful and it's everything
that it should be
and then on a dime it flips upside down
and there's just
it is just crazy high high conflict
but you're talking about your interest
he doesn't see it but you're talking
about your marriage
in a very you have distanced yourself
from it just in your language you're
talking
very evasively about your language about
your marriage you're talking very
evasively about one another
and so cut right to the middle of it
is are you all too lying to each other
are y'all seeing other people
or no you spoiled or no
there's no sexual infidelity but there's
some serious emotional problems
okay you know and and we're 16 years
into marriage and you know 10 11 years
ago i started going to counseling and
you know i've had my own i've had my own
problems and it's been it's been a
journey there
um you know but there's the other side
of it and it's and it's almost like the
healthier
i get in some really definitive clear
clinically measurable ways
the more um the kind of crazier and just
and
the more just dysfunctional and messed
up the marriage
becomes and at this point it's just
unhinged right
to the point where it's just not safe to
live together so um
so when how long have you been separated
you know i i moved out about a year ago
but even that was super super gradual
where i'd still come home to the main
house and then just go sleep
at the other house so how long have you
been separated though
uh you know and and so since last summer
i've been
you know more at the other house
completely but we're still sitting here
wrestling with kids
and trying to work that out and to tell
you the truth even before
a year ago we were sleeping in different
rooms for
a lot of years how old are your kids
john
my oldest is 15 and my youngest is four
okay
how many in between ah there's four
total
yeah john can i is your marriage over
i hope not i'm i'm swinging for a
miracle
okay is your wife swinging for a miracle
i think she is i think she is from where
she's standing yeah
okay um for sure when's the last time
you two went to see somebody for an
intensive and so for those of you don't
know an intensive is when you go sit
with somebody
a marriage counselor sometimes you'll go
see a marriage group
for four hours at a time sometimes back
to back
and say we are going all in and there's
even specialized therapists that will
tell you at the end of a four-hour
session or an eight-hour session
or end of a weekend this doesn't have
the legs to it you all need to begin to
to solidify the separation or they'll
say yeah the this
we moved some of the wood some of the
ashes out man there are some
still some embers burning in here have
you all done that
you know we did she's always refused
counseling and then with divorce on the
table last fall
we started going to see a therapist and
uh you know i'll tell you
that did not go well okay that was
you know make your head spin um
you know where where the the end of the
first
you know several sessions with the first
therapist you know their
life and her are yelling at each other
so let's start seeing another therapist
and then we spend the rest of the time
complaining about me well i sit there
trying to swallow
and and i can't do that either so here's
the thing john
you can't i'm using your words back to
you
you can't tell me that both of you
desperately want to do this
but one of you won't go you can't tell
me that both of you desperately want to
do this
but one person keeps being dishonest
about
our joint checking accounts or joint
money right
this i don't want to be the
guy that tells you i think this thing's
run its course i think this thing is
over and you all need to be serious
about where you're moving
forward i would give it one more shot
and i would go to an intensive
and it's going to be tough and it's
going to be hard and you're going to
have to be honest with one another
you're going to be honest with a
therapist
and then if it is over for the sake of
you two and for these children
you've gotta act like adults and
separate like adults
give it one more shot brother this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show
today's scripture hebrews 4 12
for the word of god is living and active
sharper than any two-ed sword piercing
to the division of
soul and of spirit of joints and of
marrow
and discerning the thoughts and
intentions of the heart
today's quote a ship in the harbor is
safe
but that is not what ships are built for
john augusta [ __ ]
pretty cool all right listen we are
excited to take your calls here
dr daloni and i if you're out there and
you want to talk about something i want
you to give us a call
uh that phone number is two two
888-825-5225
again that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five
we'd love to be able to hear from you
all right next up we've got uh david on
the line david what's your
question for john and i hey guys how you
doing
doing all right my friend how are you
today
good good my question is
something i've been struggling with
lately i didn't think i would be
i've been feeling kind of jealous
and almost resentful seeing some of my
friends get some of these big
stimulus packages you know they're going
out they're
buying cars some of them are working the
system
still getting all this money and i know
they're my friends but i don't know why
i'm feeling like this and it's really
bothering me
hmm i mean
go ahead is this normal or do you think
there's more than
just me there's a bunch of other people
thinking this or
am i just a crazy one no i had a
conversation this past weekend
um i had never heard this term before
hogan is a group of young folks 25
26 couldn't wait to get their stemies
they're second or third that's what
they're calling them now
right it's like a life bonus coming from
the clouds
yeah hey so here's the thing david
it i mean no you're not crazy right
you're not
um your brain's working just fine what
i'll tell you is
jealousy just poisons you right it ruins
your day makes you sick
makes you not well it doesn't affect any
of the car your buddies are purchasing
right i know it does solidify your
values
you may be feeling a little bit like
whoa i thought i knew you guys
and i don't think i do does this mean
i'm gonna have to start thinking about
new friend groups
new community groups like so it when you
see friends or people that you've
been right or died with for a while man
not that they have different beliefs we
all got different beliefs but you start
to see their values are different than
yours
man that's hard you mourn that because
you know you're gonna have to make some
friend transitions over time right
but it's not it's not abnormal to feel
jealous
i tell you it's a complete and utter
waste of your time your energy and your
soul
mm-hmm it destroys you from inside i get
that
and i don't know why it's just bothering
me while i'm feeling like that
i think it's i think it's good that
you've been able to put your finger on
what you're feeling yeah
right like that that's that's fantastic
brother now it's a matter of what do you
do next
now correct me if i'm wrong david but
how what do you mean they're buying a
car
what's a stimulus check like are they
getting a different level of check that
i'm hearing about in the news
well i guess see they all have kids me
and my wife don't
we weren't able to uh for certain
reasons that's that's a whole nother
show with dr david anyway
um that's you know
i feel in my mind i'm like should you
all be saving some of this money for
your kids or your future
so brother you know going out and
putting a it is a separate show
listen it is a separate show but it's
not nope
it's all wound up there together yep and
it's just
one more one more one more ding
one more come on man right
and it hurts and it's just a reminder
right and
the first time all those your buddies
start posting their
first day of kindergarten pictures
that's going to come back and they start
posting their high school graduation
all that's going to be there um
and so your everything about your life
your marriage your um work
your friends your church group anybody
you connected with
the faster you can resolve in your heart
to put that stuff down
the better and lighter you're gonna walk
through through life
so instead of it hurting and going what
do you guys do
man your friends or your friends either
disconnect from them or go over there
and say
you bought a car you're an idiot let's
go for a ride man right
maybe it's because me and my wife are
working the baby steps and they're not
that's it it's all around all of that
yeah
and and i would say you know it comes
back to
i like that you're aware of this and i
like that you're able to name it
beautiful and the fact that you would
just free flow and talk about the
kid thing that's a big chunk of this
you know but you guys coming back and
being in in
in focus on what it is you're doing you
and i know
people love to live fake rich okay
people love to play like everything's
okay
but the reality is is what's happening
inside their house
you really don't know and it's really
none of your business
you want to work your plan and your
steps to get to where it is you want to
go
so i just would redirect that energy and
let it fuel you
toward what it is you can control you
and your wife together
um here's a quick tip whenever you feel
your buddy calls and says hey come check
out this car i just got a seven thousand
dollar stemi
and i'm gonna go buy a car with it and
you get that initial
pissed off you know that feeling say
yeah i'll be over tonight you can give
me a test drive i want you to lean into
it and i want you to celebrate it with
them
even if it's hard even if it's hard when
they
when they post something about their
kids halloween costume and your first
thought is
come on why not us i want you to
make sure you got candy for that little
kid right i want you to lean into that
stuff and over time
that that spirit of frustration that
spirit of jealousy that spirit of
why them and not me you you begin to
celebrate life with them not against
them
and here's the thing you and your wife
opted in on this baby step deal
don't go around hating on other people
who aren't as enlightened and as wise as
you are choosing to be okay
part of this journey is like you know we
talk about you don't get to go out to
eat and you miss out on those things
we probably could do a better job
talking about your friends will not want
to be friends with you
or you will resent other people because
they're living a life that you wish you
were living
but you're making the hard decisions now
so that down the road
you've got more gas in the tank and and
the reality is is you're going to put
yourself in a position to be able to do
more
uh you're living the example right now
as i call it you're going through the
tough
right you're going through the tough
part right now and on the other side
brother it's better it really is but it
is a matter of kind of withstanding that
and i want to encourage you to do this
what you're feeling and what you talked
about with john and i here
i want you to get with your wife and i
want you guys to sit down and i want you
to ask
each other hey how do you feel or what
what do you wish you could tell them
and i wish i could tell and i want you
guys once you get kind of that out of
your system
now go back to hey what can we control
why are we doing what we're doing
what's the stuff we're motivated to do
and dream out loud and kind of work
together but it's important to stay
aligned
yeah just i is as hard as it is to do
do the hard work of putting down those
heavy
ugly mean emotions man especially don't
go to the internets and leave comments
solves nothing yeah oh people get
digital muscles
all the time it's ridiculous you know i
read something it said hate
it's like drinking poison and expecting
someone else to die that's right
and that's jealousy's the same way
jealousy is too so
you know in that you got to find a way
to channel it and again i appreciate you
calling in david
uh being able to let that out you're a
brave dude but you are brave he really
is and he's aware
but it's really important to not only
let that out but then come up with
what's the system that i'm gonna do
what's my decision tree in handling this
because it's going to pop back up that's
right and i can't let it get to level 10
so i can address it at level 2. that's
exactly right
so in the nerd world we call this the
fundamental attribution error
and and an easy way to think of it is
i'm going to get inside your head
and i know why you did what you just did
yeah right i'm making a decision as to
ah
he cut me off in traffic because he is
the worst
not hey he cut me off in traffic he's
probably hauling over to the er
to see somebody that he loves we get to
choose while i'm driving my little car
which one of those scenarios i put that
driver into one of them is gonna
make me wreck my car give me high blood
pressure like make my liver fail right
the other one is gonna give me peace
right it's to help me honor my
my fellow man my fellow woman and allow
you to experience some grace and i'm
going to live longer too
that's really cool well listen i want to
thank all you callers for taking time to
call in
i want to thank producer james child and
associate producer kelly daniel
thank you john we had a lot of fun good
show here today
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you